the New York Times touts a new study
saying disparities between black and
white children are based on racism
president Trump congratulate
Putin on a sham election and Democrats
threaten civil war a lot to get to I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so good morning at 11:06
eastern time I declared a coup I am now
president of the United States the
current government of the United States
has been dissolved in its entirety and
all of them will be replaced by non
corrupt non prostitutes tipping people
this is how this is going to work from
here on in the IRS has been dissolved
and I declare a thumb war as well your
new American Republic however is brought
to you by our friends at Birch gold so
Birch gold the place you need to be if
you are interested in hedging against
the volatility of the stock market if it
looks like the stock market has been
bouncing around like a ping-pong ball
lately that's because it has there's
some inherent volatility apparently the
feds gonna raise interest rates again
you don't follow any of the stuff but
you want to take a small portion of your
wealth and put it in precious metals to
guard against the vicissitudes of the
market well that is what Birch gold is
there for my friends over at Birch gold
have a long-standing track record of
continued success with thousands of
satisfied clients countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact them my Birch
gold group now to request a free
information kit on physical precious
metals they have a comprehensive 16 page
kit and it reveals how gold and silver
can protect your savings how you can
legally move your IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA again these are the folks I
trust for precious metals investing to
get your no cost no obligation kit go to
www.hsn
that's wwr cool calm / pen so you wonder
where is your new studio mr. Shapiro
well my new studio is directly outside
the speaker of the houses office
actually this office right here this
magnificent two office festoon with
American flags and bust of George
Washington just behind these flags the
true American president this office was
apparently the place where President
Trump right after his inauguration went
to sign a bunch of bills and also tweet
some stuff and and so it is very
important for that reason I will not I
will not suggest what has happened on
this desk I don't know so I can't
speculate you know maybe some things
about but I don't know I just can't
spend but and later today I'm gonna be
speaking with the Speaker of the House
which should be an honor and a privilege
for him for me I know it'll be it'll be
great and I'm looking forward to talking
with him but there's a lot of news
that's happening so I've been asked by a
lot of people to go through a study that
was reported yesterday by the New York
Times so one of the main issues that has
become up cropped up so often in
American society these days is of course
racism racism that's and racism that and
racial disparities are in
negative the horror of American life and
America's racism problem is what has
generated income inequality between
black folks and white folks and this is
brand-new study from the New York Times
complete with massive beautiful graphics
all about how black people can't get
ahead in America here was the headline
from The New York Times yesterday
hey extensive data shows punishing reach
of racism for black boys has a pretty
shocking headline right for the New York
Times which usually ends around zits
headlines usually it says something like
data sometimes suggests black people
have to have face discrimination in
certain areas people say right that's a
normal New York Times headline so this
one's a hard-hitting and headline
extensive data shows punishing reach of
racism for black boys okay so what
exactly does the study show and this is
a pretty important study and I think
it's important to deconstruct the
studies that we know what we're talking
about when we talk about whether racism
is responsible for some of the
imbalances we see in American life now
this is not to imply that racism hasn't
been a historic part of America of
course it has this is not to imply but
there is not racism today of course
there is what this is to suggest is that
this study which is being really touted
as the the final data on racism in
America demonstrating that only racism
is responsible for the difference in
income outcome between black folks and
white folks that study it that's not
what the study says so according to the
New York Times young black men lag
behind young white men not because of
behavioral differences not because young
black men commit more crimes than young
white men on average or because they
have a lower educational background or
because they have single dads but
because of widespread American racism
here is what The Times reports black
boys raised in America even in the
wealthiest families and living in some
of the most well-to-do neighborhoods
still earn less in adulthood than white
boys with similar backgrounds according
to a sweeping new study that traced the
lives of millions of children white boys
who grew up rich are likely to remain
that way black boys raised at the top
however are more likely to become poor
than to stay wealthy in their own adult
household so what this study's main
finding was is that if a black kid black
young black boy grows up in a rich
household in Beverly Hills next to a
rich white family in Beverly Hills with
a young white boy that the black boy is
more likely to fall into poverty than
the white boy even though they start off
in the same area and with the same
two-parent family and so this must
obviously be due to racism red this is
the New York Times's take on the study
according to The Times quote gets
persisted even when black and white boys
grew up in families with the same income
similar family structure similar
education levels and even similar levels
of accumulated wealth so that are moving
all the factors that people would
normally suggest contribute to
disparities between black income and
white income they're saying even when a
rich black kid grows up rich and black
with two parents and goes to that high
school and all the stuff they still have
lower outcomes than white folks and the
IQ is not the problem right so there
there are some people who are who are
racially suggestive we shall say who say
that maybe this is because black folks
have lower IQs on average than white
folks the data is not there to suggest
that the reason the data is not there to
suggest that is because the income
outcome right the outcome of income for
for black women is exactly the same as
for white women who grow up rich so the
disparity only exists between young
black men and young white men it does
not exist between young black women and
young white women so if you have a rich
black girl who grows up next to a rich
white girl they basically are going to
have exactly the same income as their
life progresses so as I acknowledge
right the study openly acknowledges that
the racism doesn't extend to black women
so first of all this gives the lied to a
lot of the intersectional nonsense you
hear from the left so the case for
intersectionality is that everyone's
experience is different and is
predicated upon group differences a
black woman is both black and a woman
this means that she has two status
symbols right being a female means that
she has somehow been victimized by
American society and being a and being
black means she's been victimized that
means a black woman has been more
victimized than a black male may the
studies suggest the opposite actually
this study actually suggests that young
black men do worse in American society
than black women so so much for that
intersectional point but this this
finding that no income gap exists
between black and white women raised in
similar households should also make
youth wonder is this really about racism
is racism the dividing line because
again black women happened to be black
so if black women have the same outcomes
as white women when given the same
circumstances wouldn't that suggest that
racism is not actually the central
problem right black women aren't not
black just because they're treated well
by the surrounding community right this
is that that's a foolish argument the
study itself says that black women
earned slightly more than white women
conditional on parent income there is
little or no gap in wage rates or hours
of work between black and white women
and black women also have a higher
college attendance rate than white men
conditional on parental outcome non
parental income rather so immediately
should give you some serious pause as to
the headline those espoused by the New
York Times again the New York Times
headline here was extensive data shows
punishing reach of racism for black boys
they're already attributing all of the
difference between black boys and white
boys to racism even though that racism
parently just disappears with regard to
black women which is kind of weird I'd
immediately should wonder is racism
really the dividing factor here or is it
the black women and black men actually
have different perspectives on
decision-making processes in higher
income households whereas it possible
that young black men and young black
women are encouraged for two different
activities even in higher income
households with two parents and the
study also finds that income gaps
between whites and Hispanics are
converging and will disappear in very
short order asian-americans actually
earn more than whites raised at the same
income level so again mr. Collins a
question if America's such a deeply
racist place why is it only racist
apparently against black boys right not
against black women not against
Hispanics not again a not against Asians
just against black boys and this should
make you wonder it's also worth noting
that one of the chief arguments in favor
of the notion that blacks suffer under
regime of white privilege when they say
that you know people like me can't speak
on politics because we remember of white
privilege class and the system was built
for us one of the arguments for white
privilege is that black people suffer in
the United States today because of
historic wealth gap that because black
people were subject to slavery and Jim
Crow they have less wealth in the
families in which they grow up okay well
there is that wealth gap but the study
demonstrates that family wealth is
actually not an indicator of continued
life success for black men so even when
black men are growing up with a
tremendous amount of wealth they're
having poorer outcomes in terms of
income then white men are so that
suggests that wealth is actually not the
primary differentiating factor between
the outcome of people's earning power so
this is the big question of the study
the big question of the study is our
black men failing in a way black women
are not because of discrimination or is
it because of differences in behavior so
my suggestion is there would have
something to do with differences in
behavior and the study itself suggests
this right this is not the stuff the New
York Times wants to cover it's all
buried in the 100 page study that I read
yesterday for example the study
discusses criminal behavior among
high-income young black men but it
doesn't actually investigate the
possible causal link between criminal
behavior and drop in income so the study
says that black men raised in the top 1%
of income right people who are
millionaires or
as likely to be incarcerated as white
men raised in households earning about
$36,000 a year so is that the fault of
white races that's an amazing statistic
that means that a black kid growing up
in a millionaire household is as likely
to go to prison as a white kid growing
up in a household earning $36,000 is
that the result of racism or is that the
result of bad individual behavior is it
really that the police are staking out
Beverly Hills for young black men who
live in that area and then just
arresting them willy-nilly or is it
possible the criminal rates in among
young black men even upper income areas
are higher than they are among young
black women for example and it has
nothing to do with race it has to do
instead with certain cultural
implication which I'll get to in just a
second in fact the study itself
recognizes that incarceration is not the
result of surrounding racism that those
incarceration rates that are elevated
for young black men and rich areas are
not actually the result of surrounding
racism they say that this that the
relationship between racism in a given
area and incarceration rates quote is
not statistically significant meaning
that young black men are not being
arrested just as the cops are a bunch of
racists in Beverly Hills as a sidebar
and this is an important point high
black crime rates do have horrible
externalities for innocent young black
men I want to talk about this in a
little bit because here's the area where
racism really sort of does play a role
because I don't think the racism is a
completely irrelevant factor but I don't
think it's quite racism either I think
that it's a form of discrimination the
Thomas Sowell talks about and I'll talk
about that in in just a second other
differences between young black men and
and young black women is that the study
indicates that the impact of
neighborhood on young black men matters
young black men do best in neighborhoods
with low levels of racism the study
actually it's measurements of racism are
really suspect they use the implicit
assessment test the implicit bias
assessment test which is which is not a
good test and high levels of fatherhood
in the community at large so young black
boys do better when there are dads in
the community what's interesting is that
the study suggests it's not even having
black men in the home it's not even
about having a father in the home it's
about our there are high levels of black
men in the community who can play the
father figure role so that's that's an
interesting thing more social fabric
helps raise boys better whether they are
white or black but these communities are
pretty rare right single motherhood does
remain prevalent in the black community
and the study admits quote the fraction
of low-income black fathers presence is
most predictive of
intergenerational gaps so again it's
about single motherhood it is not really
about racism black boys who grew up in
areas with high father presence are also
significantly less likely to be
incarcerated which could explain part of
the association with higher employment
rates so I will get to the end of this
study and a word about discrimination in
just a second first I want to say thank
you for sponsors over at Indo Chino so
you want to look like James Bond you
want to look like the thing then all you
need to do is go over to Indo Chino
because the fact is you could go buy a
suit off the rack and won't look that
great on you unless you happen to be a
specified size or you can have a suit
made to order just for you by the folks
over in know Chino they're the world's
largest made-to-measure
menswear company that make suits and
shirts they're created to your exact
measurements for a great fit I've been
to the Indo Chino workshop over in
Beverly Hills and it is just fantastic
they allow you to personalize your suit
they allow you to pick how you want the
lapels to look they allow you to pick
the color the lining everything it
actually is a lot of fun and not only
that the suit fits fantastically well or
you can go online and submit your
measurements and they'll send it
directly to your house and you have all
the same abilities to personalize your
suit again you go there you pick your
fabric you choose your customizations
you submit your measurements and then
you just wait for the custom suit to
arrive in a few weeks it's endo chinos
calm and right now my listeners get any
premium Enzo Chino suit for just 379
bucks at Indo Chino comm when you enter
Shapiro at checkout again that's Indo
Chino calm when you enter Shapiro at
checkout you get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just three hundred seventy nine
dollars that is 50% off the regular
price for a made-to-measure premium suit
and shipping is free check it out Indo
Chino comm promo code Shapiro that lets
them know that we sent you and also you
get the best looking so you've ever worn
any premium suit for just 379 bucks plus
free shipping as well and they really
are terrific they make a mistake to help
you correct it it's really it's really
great endo Chino comm and again use that
promo code Shapiro at checkout okay so
back to the study that the New York
Times calls a damning indictment of
American racism with regarding black
boys what I have suggested is that the
data from the study actually suggests
that differentiations between the
outcomes for rich young black men and
young black women for example or young
black men and young white men has little
to do with generalized American racism
and a lot to do with personal choices
that are being made in the black
community even in areas that are more
wealthy right so the study tries to
attribute to generalized racism a little
bit
what this differentiation between young
black men and young white men even if
they are both rich right the studies
take on racism is actually its weakest
methodologically it uses that implicit
association test as I suggested this is
the implicit bias test if you've been in
college they've forced you to take an
IAT what that is that's stupid test
where you're supposed to click on words
as black and white faces appear and what
it's supposed to show is that if you
click on negative words when a black
face appears more quickly then you click
on negative words when a white face
appears this is your supposed racism the
problem is that the implicit assessment
test actually doesn't measure real-world
racism nor is it even duplicate if you
take the test twice you can game the
system all right so you can take the
test ones and it'll come up as your
racist you take it again and now you're
not a racist anymore so the test is not
actually duplicable it's not a good
measurement the study itself states that
closing the gap between whites and
blacks is largely driven by high rates
of father presence among low-income
blacks and the study even dismisses
right this is the stuff all the stuff
near times didn't report right the New
York Times headline is that America's
racist and black boys are suffering
here's what the New York Times didn't
report there's a direct quote from the
study policies focused on improving the
economic outcomes of a single generation
such as cash transfer programs or
minimum wage increases are less likely
to have persistent effects unless they
also effect intergenerational mobility
so in other words the Democrats favorite
methods of closing this gap they don't
do anything
not only that forced integration in
schools in housing won't do anything
either they'll quote also likely leave
much of the gap in place since the gap
persists even among low-income children
raised on the same block so all of the
left favorite policy prescriptions that
would rise from that that shocking
headline from the New York Times the
study itself rejects so what exactly is
the difference so what exactly is the
difference between why young black men
who are growing up rich with two-parent
families and young white men growing up
the same way have different outcomes
what would explain that well one theory
that was put forward by black
anthropologist John Abu since the 1980s
theorized that black children were offer
are often penalized socially for acting
white okay those aren't my words those
are the words of Barack Obama here's a
Barack Obama said in 2004 quote children
can't achieve unless we raise their
expectations and turn off the television
sets and eradicate the slander that says
a black youth of the book is acting
white and in fact repeated studies have
shown that even in high-income areas
black students spend less time on
studying than white students
particularly black males Morocco
reiterated this in 2014 he said there's
an element of truth in the accusation
that too many black parents denigrate
education we're ok if boys are reading
too much than what why are you doing
that or why are you speaking so properly
right this was a serious question that
was asked about Barack Obama in 2008 by
people on the left is he black enough
because he doesn't speak in Ebonics and
because the president used to the the
the ex-president used to you know had a
very mellifluous speaking voice and if
he turned on the radio you wouldn't know
whether he was white or black and use
particular dialects or there's a lot of
talk is he is he too white right is
Clarence Thomas too white they are
educated black people too white this is
this is a serious issue that there are a
lot of people who have faced larry elder
has talked about this a lot thomas soul
has talked about this there is a
cultural denigration in certain parts of
black community against education by the
way this exists in certain parts of the
white community as well in hillbilly
elegy JD Vance talked specifically about
this in impoverished white communities
in Appalachia for example communities
that value education and that promote
education are more likely to have
children who value education promote
education and end up with better life
outcomes the reason that agents
outperform whites is because Chinese
American culture and Korean American
culture to take a couple of examples are
heavily focused on education and
achievement this is also true of Jewish
Americans who came to the United States
dirt-poor and tested below average on IQ
tests before they before they acclimated
and ended up becoming one of the
wealthier subgroups in the United States
black children has been significantly
less time on homework than any other
race of children Asian children spend
significantly more time on homework it
makes a difference Harvard's Roland
fryer another black scholar formalized a
particular peer effect acting white
which potentially contributes to the
ongoing puzzle of black underachievement
his suggestion is that you are socially
ostracized if you spent too much time
studying as a young black male the New
York Times doesn't go into any of that
of course all they do is they just they
say young black men's you worse than
young white men that must be to some
greater racist issue now here is where
discrimination comes in I promised you
there would be discussion of
discrimination here is the discussion of
discrimination so there are three types
of discrimination at the end of the show
I'm going to talk about things I like
him to recommend Thomas Sol's book
Natalia is a brand new book out on
discrimination gonna interview him for
the show Thomas olds one my favorite
thinkers people have asked me before if
I were not declaring the Clunes of
clearing myself president today who
would I do that for and I've said that I
would do that for Thomas tole who they
think is the best thinker in the country
at Thomas solos book he talks about
three
separate types of discrimination and
it's important for us to distinguish
these things in our mind so that we are
exact when we use words like
discrimination okay so there are three
types discrimination type number one is
the type of discrimination you use every
day no you're not a racist you
discriminate between behavioral choices
right you decide who is going to be a
friend who is not based on whether
somebody will drive you to the airport
you decide whether or not you want to
date someone based on whether they are
nice to you you decide whether you want
to hire someone based on whether you
think they're likely to steal the
silverware now you make all of these
decisions based on individual data and
individual behavior that's not racism
right that's just what we do every day
we're always making these decisions our
entire day is a series of discriminatory
decisions that we make against one
particular choice and in favor of
another that's totally innocent
discrimination this is what Thomas soul
calls type 1a discrimination then there
is type 2 discrimination type 2
discrimination is the absolute overt all
right racism black people are inferior
they're genetically inferior and
therefore we can't hire them they
shouldn't be allowed into schools we
should live apart from them etc etc
right that is actual outright
discrimination and racism that exists
but it's a relatively small amount in
the you know it's a very low level in
the United States in fact I would I
would suggest that racism across the
world is much higher than it is in the
United States then there is the type of
discrimination that is somewhere in the
middle okay this is what Thomas all
calls discrimination 1b so remember one
a was you discriminating amongst choices
one B is you discriminating about
individuals based on group data so here
is the example that Thomas Sola uses
right for discrimination one be if 40%
this is from this new book
discrimination and in diversity is it
called I'll try and describe disparities
thank you it's discrimination
disparities so here is the example if
40% of people in group X are alcoholics
and 1% of people in group Y are
alcoholics an employer may well prefer
to hire only people from group Y for
work where an alcoholic would not only
be ineffective but dangerous so you have
a taxi company and you're not allowed to
do criminal background check so you're
not allowed to know whether someone's
ever had a DUI all you know is that
people in group of a group acts 40% of
them drive drunk and all you know is
that in group Y you know the second
group only 1% some people do that's all
the information you have who do you
choose to drive your taxi and we make
these sorts of decisions every day right
Jesse Jackson once said about walking
down the street at night
see Jackson said if I'm walking down the
street at night and I see a young black
man coming at me and a hoodie I crossed
the street was that Jesse Jackson being
racist or is that him using group data
in order to make a decision about what
to do here and now based on the risk
assessment right what it really is is
this discrimination one day now it makes
us all a little bit queasy right it
makes us a little bit uncomfortable
because what we would prefer is that we
all see each other as individuals that
we have all the information available
when there's certain legislative efforts
in place that actually prevent this so
for example President Obama said that he
wanted federal employees to never be
able to be tested for criminal
background checks he wanted federal
contractors not to be able to test for
criminality in background checks of
employees because he said too many black
young black men have gone to prison and
then they won't be able to get a job
afterward well the actual effect of that
policy is to lower black employment
according to a study in 2001 because
what to employers do when they're told
that they can't do criminal background
checks
instead of screening out people core
actually criminals or who had a criminal
record instead of doing that what they
do is they screen out entire populations
they say okay the criminal rate in the
black community is much higher than the
criminal rate in the white community and
this is particularly true among young
black males so I just learned hire young
black males because I can't check
whether the person is a criminal or not
I can only use the data at hand is that
racism or is that just the use of group
data without any further investiture of
time okay and what we can so there's two
things that we can do to to stop this
sort of discrimination I'll explain the
two things we can do to stop
discrimination one be in just a second
and this is really where I think we
should be putting some of our efforts
but first I need to say thank you to our
sponsors over at the u.s. ECA so mass
shootings terror attacks that can happen
as we've seen Anytime Anywhere
unfortunately London Paris New York
Vegas parkland after every tragedy the
politicians blame the only people who
need the protection the most law-abiding
people right this is what they do
they're constantly blaming people like
me and people like you you're a gun
owner and they say well why don't you
just give up your AR then the media show
a video of some idiot so long off the
end of their AR and being prosecuted for
sawing off the end of their AR and
making the gun a new legal weapon right
this is what the media constantly do but
now you can actually fight back yeah you
can get the complete mass shooting
Survival Guide from the US ECA it is
100% free you can claim yours for a very
limited time at defend my family now
calm
that's defend my family now calm and in
this guide you will learn what we really
know about mass shootings
how to survive an attack proven
strategies for stopping shooter and a
whole lot more Plus us CC ages wonderful
work and ensuring that you are legally
prepared in case god forbid you have to
pull the trigger on somebody who's
attempting to hurt you
Plus this entire packet comes with a
bonus audio book so you can listen
whenever you want as soon as you finish
my podcast you can claim yours in
seconds right now it's 100% free and for
a very limited time you will also get a
bonus security checklist for your office
church or school go to defend my family
now dot-com while you still can that's
defend my family now calm again defend
my family now calm you'll see CIA has a
bunch of fantastic services they provide
to you plus you can get that complete
mass shooting Survival Guide from the US
you see a 100% free again
great folks over there defend my family
now calm that's defend my family now
calm okay so back to discrimination so
the reason that this actually plays a
role with regard to the study that we're
talking about is let's take my
suggestion for just a second that one of
the reasons that we see lower-income
outcomes I know it's confusing when I
say income outcome what I mean is lower
earnings outcomes for young black men
than young white men who grow up in the
same cohort why exactly do we see that
I'm saying maybe it's individual choices
maybe it's educational disparities
brought on by cultural disdain in
certain parts of the black community for
education the acting white phenomena
they they're a bunch of factors that
need to be taken into account the study
doesn't actually take into account but
let's start with criminality
so let's suggest that these statistics
really are stunning that something like
ten percent of young black men in the
top in the in the top quintile actually
have been convicted of a crime it's a
it's something insane it's a really
really high number and let's say that we
have all these bans on the books that
prevent you from doing federal
background checks criminal background
checks on your employees and so
employers start using broad-based
discrimination based on data so they
start using group data because they
can't use individual data and that means
that innocent young black men are caught
up in the court and just like in the
Alcoholics case sixty percent of the
group of people who are considered more
alcoholic are not alcoholic but those
people are not being hired because all
the taxi company cares about is not
hiring any alcoholics and they've been
prevented from screening for DUI
background right so there are two ways
to prevent this one is to take away the
government disincentive to actually do
the research so get rid of regulations
on the books that don't allow you to do
criminal background checks right get rid
of the regulations on the books that
prevent people in housing from doing
criminal background checks it has been a
serious issue there been a lot of local
areas that refused to allow people who
own apartment buildings for example to
do criminal background checks of of
their potential clients of potential
residents at their at their house well
if I'm renting out my garage I won't
know whether the guy's a criminal or not
and if I'm not allowed to check whether
the guy's a criminal I'm just gonna rent
I'm gonna rent to the Amish guy down the
road because the criminal rate in the
Amish community is really low right you
can you can actually play this forward
not even with regard to black and white
you can play forward to any community
the criminal rate in the Amish community
extremely well if I have a choice
between the the normal non Amish white
guy and the Amish guy I will choose the
Amish guy every time to occupy my garage
right is that discrimination or is that
a database group decision that has
nothing to do with racism it has to do
just with group data that you are now
applying
okay so how do you get past that number
one you remove the disincentive now you
people's individuals you do a criminal
background check yes that means the
people with the criminal record probably
won't get hired but guess what it also
means that innocent people of the same
race or of the same group as the people
with the criminal record will get hired
and this is what that 2001 study showed
when you got rid of regulations
preventing criminal background checks
more black people were hired so every
time the left tries to help by
preventing employers from gathering
information employers simply use group
data which is a worse kind of data so
that's something that has to change the
second thing that has to change is you
need to change the group data the group
data itself has to change so the
criminal rates in the Jewish community
when Jews first came over from Eastern
Europe in the early 20th century were
actually not low they were quite high
okay they were quite high in the Italian
community when Italian immigrants first
came to the United States and the Irish
community there was a reason where it
said no Jews need apply no Irish need
apply no Italians need apply this has
been true a virtually every single
ethnic group that has ever entered the
United States when they first get here
they are poor and very often admired in
crime
and then over the course of generations
the crime stops well if you are going to
prevent group data from for being used
as a basis for discrimination one be in
Thomas soles modeling then what you
really need to focus on is how do you
get that criminal rate down now what the
study suggests is the first thing you
need to do is ensure that their fathers
in the community again an individual
decision an individual decision having
nothing to do with racism as I've said
many times in my speeches on this
program there's not a black man in
America who was forced at gunpoint to
impregnate a black woman and leaves okay
not by white racist okay this has never
happened or if it has then it would be
criminal and we'd prosecute it okay
individual decision-making is usually
responsible for even group disparity
okay because there are cultural
differences because there are histories
because there are pathologies of poverty
all of this is true has nothing to with
race by the way nothing I'm saying here
has anything to do with implicit rates
rhyming this happens among white people
what happens among black people
it's much more about behavior than about
race so what I would suggest is that if
you actually want to get rid of
discrimination 1 B and get down to the
level where we treat everybody as
individuals take away the bureaucratic
and economic incentives to make group
decisions and number 2 make sure that
the group data itself changes by
bringing enough cops into crime ridden
communities to ensure that the crime
rate actually goes down rather than
continuing to go up okay so the reason
I spent so much time on this is because
number one I got a lot of emails about
this particular study but number two
because I think that it's indicative of
what the media want the media only
quoted a certain segment of the study
right they said this shows that racism
is responsible for young black boys not
succeeding in America and then it's
pretty obvious they didn't even analyze
the vast majority of the study right
that entire section near the end where
they say that forced housing integration
is not gonna work and forced busing is
not going to work and income
redistribution is not going to work
right all of that was left out by the
New York Times who shows you the media
bias when they are in pursuit of a
particular agenda okay so now I want to
talk about a controversy that has broken
out over president Trump of course some
President Trump
well apparently call the Vladimir Putin
the dictator of Russia who won an
overwhelming election victory in the
least surprising result since Fidel
Castro won an overwhelming election
victory you know he is a dictator
okay Russia is a dictatorship people
like dictatorship for reasons I
explained on Monday when I talk about
romantic nationalism presidents from
made a boo-boo okay in the booboo
President Trump called up Putin and he
said congratulations on your magnificent
election victory here is from talking
about it I had a call with President
Putin and congratulated him on the
victory his electoral victory the call
had to do also with the fact that we
will probably get together in the
not-too-distant future so that we can
discuss arms we could discuss the arms
race as you know he made a statement
that being in an arms race is not a
great thing that was right after the
election one of the first statements he
made and also to discuss Ukraine and
Syria and North Korea and various other
things okay so the part that's it's
troubling is obviously not to talk about
the arms race the part that's troubling
is where he says that he congratulated
Putin so it has now been leaked to The
Washington Post
but Trump did not follow specific
warnings from his national security
advisers on Tuesday when he
congratulated Putin there was apparently
a section in his briefing materials in
all capital letters stating do not
congratulate according to officials
familiar with the call so a couple of
things one people in the White House
should not be leaking what's on national
security documents to the press okay
obviously there's some serious leak
still inside the White House the
fractious nosov the White House
is insane the fact that the stuff is
leaking is not good second of all if you
want President Trump to do something
never right in capital letters for him
not to do something okay because if the
President of the United States he is
like my four-year-old daughter who at
this point in her life says whatever the
opposite is of what I want her to say or
if I want her to stop jumping on her bed
I have to tell her that I want her to
continue jumping on her bed I never
write on a piece of paper do not
congratulate Putin and slide it in front
of the president in all capital letters
because he's just going to in his own
mind go I can congratulate whoever I
want boom roasted okay so yeah so you
know it should it should he have
congratulated Putin of course you
shouldn't have congratulated Putin
Putin's a dictator okay it's stupid to
congratulate Putin and you know the
defense of it was equally stupid Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the spokeswoman for the
White House she said that you know she
was asked about this and her answer was
a rather morally egregious here's what
she said the White House believed that
the election in Russia was free and fair
in terms of the election there were
focused on our elections we don't get to
dictate how other countries operate what
we do know is that Putin has been
elected in their country and that's not
something that we can dictate to them
how they operate we can only focus on
the freeness and the fairness of our
elections something we 100% fully
support and something we're going to
continue to do everything we can to
protect to make sure bad actors don't
have the opportunity to impact them in
any way no no no no fail no no okay w UT
what okay that is not accurate in any
way the United States has a long history
of criticizing how other countries run
their elections when they are
dictatorships but that said I'm gonna
talk a little bit about the the media
and democratic response because it is
pretty hypocritical first we're gonna
have to go over to Daily wire and
subscribe so for $9.99 a month you can
get a subscription daily wire that means
you get the rest of this magnificent
show from our brand new offices but
we're not calling it the Oval Office
we'll just call it the corner but you'll
be able to see the rest of the show I
mean we paid for this place right so you
may as well be part of it $9.99 a month
you get that you get the rest of Andrew
Klavan show live you get the rest of
Michael Knowles's show live get to be
part of my mailbag on Friday when all of
your life questions will be answered you
also got the very
best in all beverage vessels the leftist
tears hot or cold a tumbler you can
enjoy that with your annual subscription
$99 a year cheaper than the monthly
subscription so get all of those things
and oh and all the glories for the
annual subscriber price and if you just
want to listen later go over to iTunes
go over to SoundCloud go over to YouTube
make sure that you subscribe please
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so is this a smart thing for Sarah
Huckabee Sanders to say no this is a
very dumb thing for Sarah Huckabee
Sanders to say the president should not
have congratulated Putin obviously the
president has an unfortunate habit of
congratulating dictators on their
election after arrow Diwan who's the
dictator of Turkey won his election I'm
putting one in scare quotes then you
know Trump congratulated him he
shouldn't have done that it's really
dumb but to pretend this is unique is
also to be historically ignorant yeah
President Obama congratulated the
congratulated Nicolas Maduro in 2012 I
believe on his on his re-election it was
either go Chavez specifically or Nicolas
Maduro I can't member Chavez is dead at
that point but he congratulated the the
leadership in his Venezuela for its
reelection Venezuela is a communist
dictatorship where people are eating
dogs okay you don't congratulate bad
people now this is where I don't like
the what about ISM it was bad when Obama
did it and it's bad when Trump does it
you shouldn't congratulate dictators on
rigging elections for their own benefit
it's just not a good thing to do and I'm
constantly surprised by people in my own
side of the aisle who had a different
standard for Obama than they have for
Trump well you know now it's just from
politicking and all the rest well so
what so what you know there's been a big
debate in American foreign policy that I
think is not really an honest one and
that is should morality play a part in
our foreign policy
they're people who declare themselves
sort of foreign policy realist this
should be folks like Rand Paul who say
morality really shouldn't play a role in
American foreign policy but even that is
morality right that is morality as a
moral statement why should American not
play a role in other countries well
there are a couple of reasons that are
suggested one is it's none of our
business what other countries do we
can't impose ourselves on them the other
is that cost us too much money in too
much time in too much treasure these
arguments are not mutually exclusive but
they also are not identical you can make
the argument that morality should help
the tenor foreign policy but we
shouldn't spend money in this particular
place I did that with regard to for
example the the Libyan intervention or
the Syrian intervention actually you
know I think you can make fair arguments
on either side but for those who say
that morality should not dictate our
foreign policy of course morality does
dictate our foreign policy because the
whole rationale for a strong America at
home even for us existing is because we
are a moral moral system now you may say
what strengthens America is not to get
entangled in foreign battles fine but
that's it that's an argument of utility
not an argument of immorality right you
do have a moral stance I assume that
Rand Paul actually doesn't like
Russian dictatorship I assume that's the
case so you know I think that a lot of
the talk about morality and foreign
policy going out the window because from
some foreign policy realist is actually
not true I just think that that's that's
a bit of a fib and fussing over on the
part of the Trump administration now
meanwhile there's a big article over at
the Washington Post again targeting
Cambridge analytic and talking about
Cambridge analytical is the root of all
evil we've been following this story all
week because I think this whole thing is
a front I think it's very rare that I
err a quasi conspiracy theory I don't
think there's a conspiracy theory cuz I
think that all of it has been basically
said I think that Zuckerberg has not
been unclear over at Facebook about what
his agenda is what's happening here is
pretty obvious Cambridge general medica
data mines okay there's not an
accusation yet they actually did it
illegally all right the FTC is
apparently investigating if they did
something illegal they'll be prosecuted
and then we can have a scandal right but
until now there's been no allegation of
actual illegal activity there's been
allegations that they gathered an
enormous amounts of facebook data and
then cross tabulated people's personal
preferences with their politics which is
like okay whatever we all do that that's
data mining has been existence in the
United States forever this is true of
every business in the United States
every business that markets online is
putting cookies on your computer to
determine what kind of products you want
to see so they can show you those
products and you will buy them nothing
untoward happened here the reason that
people on the Left are focusing in on
Cambridge analytic on Facebook is
because they're trying to browbeat
Facebook into shutting down
dissemination of conservative
information that is the entire purpose
here the reason that Facebook has moved
as I discussed at length yesterday at
nauseam yesterday the reason that
Facebook has moved against conservatives
because Zuckerberg is on the left and
because left has pressured Facebook and
Google and YouTube and Twitter and said
that you guys are responsible for
Trump's election you need to somehow
rejigger your algorithms to prevent
those nefarious right-wingers from
taking advantage of the situation
well the scandal of the day now today's
scandal is not that they did anything
illegal but instead that they did
research on what presumed Trump voters
would like so according to Christopher
Wiley who's the the pink haired dude who
was the informant to the UK Guardian
about Cambridge analytic ah
Wiley said the both Bannon Steve Bannon
who's a stockholder in Cambridge
analytical and Rebecca Mercer whose
father Robert Mercer finance the company
participated in conference calls in 2014
in which plans to collect Facebook data
were discussed
although Wiley acknowledged it was not
clear they knew the details of how the
collection
took place Vanden approved the data
collection scheme we were proposing said
Wiley the data and analyses the
Cambridge analytical generated in this
time provided discoveries that would
later form the emotionally charged core
of trumps presidential platform said
Wiley so he said Trump wasn't in our
consciousness at that moment this was
well before he became a thing he wasn't
a client or anything the year before
Trump announced his presidential bid the
data firm had already found a high level
of alienation among young white
Americans with a conservative bent in
focus groups arranged to test messages
for the 2014 midterms these voters
responded this according to the
Washington Post these voters responded
to calls for building a new wall to
block the entry of illegal immigrants to
reforms intending to drain the swamp of
Washington's entrenched political
community and to thinly veiled forms of
racism toward African Americans called
race realism here accountant okay so the
first few messages here are utterly
anodyne right a lot of people want to
build the wall that's not racist a lot
of people want to drain the swamp
Washington is a swamp even though it's
snowing here today and and the but it's
the last thing here that I think that
the media are jumping on that is thinly
veiled forms of racism toward African
Americans called race realism okay so
that's the only reference in this
article to race and the crossover to
potential Trump voters now I don't have
enough data here to actually make a
decision as to what exactly was being
pulled we just don't know was it the
actual term race realism because rates
realism is racist okay it has been
linked to scientific racism it's the
basic idea that distinctions between
groups are racially based right not the
argument that I was making with regard
to not the argument that was making with
regard to racial differences in outcome
being linked to individual
decision-making but racial differences
in outcome being linked to racial
disparity in biology right that's race
realism if that's actually what was
being pulled that's not a good thing
that also doesn't suggest that everybody
who's a trump supporter was a race
realist or knew that they were endorsing
race realist messages it also doesn't
define race realism really specifically
in this article so I'd like to see a
little more data on that before we
declare every Trump voter racist which
is really what the The Washington Post
it seems like it wants to do here the
firm apparently also tested views of
Russian President Vladimir Putin
according to Wiley the only Florida
thing we tested was Putin it turns out
there's a lot of Americans who really
like this idea of a really strong
authoritarian leader and people were
quite defensive in focus groups of
Putin's invasion of Crimea well a that
again is not particularly surprising
that our polls done at the time open
polls right
not kimbridge analytic is doing they're
open polls about Putin at the time and
there are a lot of conservatives who are
responding to how much they disliked
Obama by saying that anybody who
humiliated Obama on the world stage was
suddenly good hey that should have been
an indicator the tribal politics had
taken over Vladimir Putin is a very bad
guy authoritarian leaders are really bad
the idea that strong and powerful is a
synonym for good is undemocratic and
unamerican
okay so this is a fight that I've been
fighting for a long time again I think
there were tribal tendencies in the last
election cycle I think those tribal
tendencies certainly existed on the
right I talked at length about the
alt-right in the last election cycle I
talked at length about my fears there
was a perversion of conservative ideas
going on toward certain authoritarian
endorsements and also toward a certain
level of identity politics based on
white based on white solidarity that I
really don't like and I think is again
on American and on an anti
constitutional it also exists I'm left
right obviously Barack Obama in 2012 and
whose data mining was data mining
specifically toward particular groups
right he had african-americans for Obama
and he had Jewish Americans for Obama
and gay Americans for Obama and women
for Obama so identity politics on the
right does exist it's a problem I think
it's a serious problem it's something
I've been railing against for well on
two years here it's not a shock to me to
find that by 2014 the identity politics
of the left had bred a pretty strong
identity politics on the right it's
something that we all have to fight
together right that's something that we
all have to fight together and I hope
that if we do fight all that together
that we will end with a more
individually oriented American politics
I think that that will be that would be
you know a better outcome here but as
for the Cambridge analytical scandal in
general I'm not seeing it I don't I
don't see anything really nefarious here
and so Democrats of course are going out
on limbs and just claiming that
something nefarious is going on without
really any evidence at this point Jackie
Speier who's a democratic representative
from California actually speculated the
Cambridge analytical was in was in bed
with you guessed it the Russians well I
think we really need to find out whether
or not in their conversations with luck
oil which is a Russian oil company
whether or not that was really a
pretense to use what is called Russian
cutouts and they were in fact informing
Russia and maybe even working with
Russia and the Trump campaign it all
comes back to why all these
relationships with
rusha okay and again that's really vague
and spire has no actual allegations to
make but she hopes that if she says
Russia Russia Russia over again then
everything looks illegitimate now back
to the identity politics point and one
of the great fears that I had when
President Trump was elected I had three
fears when President Trump was elected
fear number one was the president Trump
would be so toxic that he'd sink the
Republican agenda even if you were
president that fear still on the table
fear number two that I had about
president Trump's that he wouldn't
govern as a conservative so far that
fear has not been realized the president
has governed relatively conservative and
fear number three is that the president
would actually become a thought leader
for the Republican Party I don't think
that has happened I don't think that
people see President Trump is a thought
leader for conservatism I think the left
likes to portray him that way but I
don't think that the vast bulk of
conservatives are sitting around
wondering what Donald Trump thinks about
Russell Kirk I don't think that that's a
thing and it looks to me like
Republicans in Congress are doing a
fairly decent job of checking president
Trump's worst impulses so for example
senator in sentiment of enjoyed Leader
Mitch McConnell
he's been open and obvious about the
fact that he doesn't want Trump to fire
Robert Mueller the special investigator
so for all of trumps fulmination 'he's
over over robert muller there's no
evidence that anything's gonna happen
here here's what McConnell had to say
yesterday well look I agree with the
president's lawyers that Bob Miller
should be allowed to finish his job I
think it was a excellent appointment I
think he will lead he will go wherever
the facts lead him and I think he will
have great credibility with the American
people when he reaches the conclusion of
this investigation so I have a lot of
confidence in it so listen I think that
President Trump still Katoch safai the
Republican brand but in reality has have
Republicans fallen on bended knee to
everything Trump wants to do I think the
answer is no okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today I recommend the
book earlier it's fantastic we're gonna
have Thomas solo on the program in the
and I think next week probably it's
called discipline it's called
discrimination and disparities it's very
short book maybe 145 pages all about
whether statistical disparities are an
indicator of discrimination so it goes
right to the heart of what I was
discussing at the very beginning of the
program it was Souls model that I was
talking about when I talked about the
three types of discrimination the book
is really well thought out like
everything soil Rights soul is I think
the
thinker in American politics in the last
30 years and this book is just another
piece of evidence to that effect okay
time for a quick thing that I hate okay
so the shape of water this thing won
best picture
it is an awful film so I watched it
originally and I thought it was an awful
film and then in one Best Picture I
thought well I'll give it another shot
maybe I just missed the point so I was
on a plane to the East Coast and I
watched the movie again all I can say is
I wanted to walk off the plane okay it
is that bad it is one of the 10 worst
movies ever made I am NOT this is not an
exaggeration it is an awful awful piece
of crap okay it is good to look at right
it's a pretty looking film it is in fact
about a woman who has sex with a fish
basically which is real weird and here
is a little bit the preview and then I
will discuss how this the script is
basically written by an SJW ten-year-old
with a crayon I mean the script is just
garbage but here's what the preview
looks like she's deaf she can hear you
you clean that lab to get out this may
very well be the most sensitive asset
ever to be housed in this facility
you may think that thing looks human
stands on two legs right but we're
created in the Lord Jim you don't think
that's what the Lord looks like okay so
this movie is just okay shut it off shut
it off stop it make it stop okay this
movie is so awful in every possible way
so every single trope that you could
possibly find is in this movie right
there is the all of the the so basically
it's about a woman who is mute who falls
in love with a fish man from the Black
Lagoon
and has to help him escape the clutches
of an evil American general and his
sidekick right a bible-believing
American sidekick who also happens to be
a sexual harasser and abuser as well as
a racist and an anti-gay piece of crap
right so basically it's every possible
trope that the left has ever said about
my pens except they say it about Michael
Shannon's character and he's a villain
who just for no reason wants to cut open
this fish man this magical fish man he
doesn't want to research him or have a
conversation with him he wants to cut
him open for no reason other than
America's a terrible place and this guy
of course is trained by the military and
the military is awful it's legitimately
every lefty it's why it won Best Picture
it's every lefty Trump the fish man has
helped to escape and have sexual
pleasure with a human woman which is
again very odd and all this is aided and
abetted by the gay neighbor right the
generous and wonderful gay neighbor who
is rejected in his advances on a younger
man and the younger man I love that they
add this in the movie the younger man is
very nice to the gay man until the game
and makes advances which point he goes
well buddy and then right at that moment
in the film a black couple walks into
his diner and the young man acts racist
and black couple
so it's not enough just to say that the
guy wasn't into the whole gay thing
right he's straight they also have to
imply that the only person who would
reject a gay man's advances is a racist
right it's pretty amazing it's so
there's the the gay so the the bands of
untouchables and in this in this movie
who help fish man escape our mutant
woman who apparently we learn spoiler
alert' can breathe underwater
okay and a a gay man who's being
rejected because he's gay and a black
woman who is put upon by her stupid
husband right she's she's a sassy black
lady you put upon by her stupid husband
that's not a cliche at all in the films
there's no that's not cliched at all and
and this and this group is also aided by
an American scientist who happens to be
a Russian spy a Soviet spy right that's
how we know he's good because he's a
Soviet spy it's so bad everything about
this movie is bad every line of dialogue
brings false the way that guillermo del
toro who wrote the who wrote the script
you know basically makes excuses for all
of this is because he says that it's
it's a metaphor so this is the easy way
out right the the easy way out of the
conundrum of writing bad movies to say
it's all a metaphorical don't take it
seriously it's all surreal okay if it's
surreal writing just means you get to
write stupid crap that makes no sense
and then claim that it's a metaphor then
well done and gilma a guillermo del toro
now the movie is supremely bad don't
bother watching it i instead get a fish
tank and don't have sex with the inmates
alright so we'll be back here tomorrow
with much much more a little bit later
today we are going to be interviewing
the Speaker of the House from this the
office where I have declared my coup and
and we will be showing that a little bit
later this week looking forward to it
we'll see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing